when I'm looking at a government
institution and its really expensive and
it doesn't do the job it's supposed to
do it's time for it to go hi I'm Matt
wells for recent TV we're here at the
annual Conservative Political Action
Conference or CPAC for short and this
year we noticed something a little bit
different an undercurrent of interest in
criminal justice reform you wouldn't
necessarily expect or certainly the
establishment press doesn't expect to
hear a discussion about criminal justice
reform and prison reform at the
Conservative Political Action Conference
but in point of fact this is a big
problem it's an expensive problem it
creates problems that create more
expensive problems I knew that the
message resonated with conservatives but
i was a little skeptical that it would
resonate with as many conservatives the
I mean the the percentage of people who
support the message generally is huge
we've been getting a great reception we
got tons of people on our signup list
we've been hit in the media we were on
radio rollout this morning and talking
to a lot of folks around the country so
it's been great
nominal response conservatives come in
about three different types of flavors
you have your social conservatives and
they're really interested in second
chances and redemptions they love these
issues chuck colson kind of thing there
you go then you have kind of traditional
fiscal conservatives and they're just
worried about spending you know spending
on Corrections is now the second fastest
growing component of state budgets in
the country and then finally have the
libertarians and they've always just
been creeped out by the growing scope of
the state you know and and all three of
these groups come together and and they
find that they've come to common ground
on criminal justice we cannot let the
left once again identify correctly a
problem and then stick on top of it a
solution that makes it worse
we've gotta wrestle with the problem and
come up with solutions consistent with
conservative principles if you have the
impression that criminal justice reform
is a growing issue on the right
generally speaking yeah generally
speaking I think it is I think people
are recognizing the high cost associated
with a lot of
defacto criminal justice institutions
and that there are alternatives that
work a lot better
we shut a prison down last year
that's the message all across this
country you want to talk about real
conservative governance shut prisons
down now we did a statewide poll in
Texas in November just a few months ago
and what we found was overwhelming
support across some demographic and
ideological groups in Texas for these
reform principles so it ought to be safe
because certainly in Texas everybody
agrees that it's the right thing to do
we're we're not a soft on crime State I
hope we get the reputation of being a
smart on crime steps right we need to
really show and and prove to the
national leaders that it's working at
the state level I think before they can
get fully comfortable to begin to roll
back some of this over criminalization
this occurred at the federal level
those undercurrents start to bubble up
and other people mainstream Republicans
Democratic side of the aisle everyone
takes a look and says this is something
we can agree on there aren't many things
that the President of the United States
and his Attorney General and I agree
about Duke you know domain so Rand Paul
and Rick Perry are agreeing with Eric
Holder and the President Obama on the
need for sentencing reform it's it's
bipartisanship in a way I don't think we
see very often I think what you see is
that the left has its reasons for doing
this work we have our reasons and we end
up sort of meeting at a certain point
but we're not quite coordinating but
that's fortunate that's how you get real
legislation passed